We are following a developing
story out of Nairobi in Kenya
about a gas explosion
that's left at least three people dead
and 280 others wounded.
According to the Kenyan government,
a huge ball of fire was caused by gas
that a truck was carrying.
It apparently exploded at a gas plant
For more on the story
and a look at the scene of destruction,
we are joined by Larry.
Hi, Larry. Hi, Max.
We don't know
the cause of this explosion,
but we know that this should not be here.
This is a liquefied
petroleum gas store and filling plant.
Cooking gas is a very common,
commonly used across
not just Kenya, but across East Africa.
But this place was unlicensed
and therefore illegal
The regulator here in
Kenya says they applied for licenses
in March, in June and in July,
and they were denied all three times
for safety reasons
that to close to residential area
and therefore, in the event of a blast
like what happened last night,
it would affect so many people
that live around here
because this is a densely populated area.
And in fact, that is what happened.
So the question
for so many in this community is
why was this allowed to be here so long
even after the place was demolished
at least twice,
according to the Petroleum
Institute of East Africa,
and the owner of this place
was even convicted and jailed.
Should have gone to jail for five years,
only to have the one year sentence
and then came right back
to doing it again.
And this is the impact of that
a huge ball of fire
ignited over Nairobi's night sky
only heard
the screams of onlookers
piercing through the sound of flames.
Emergency workers racing to the scene
after a gas truck exploded
at what officials are calling
an unlicensed plant late
Thursday evening,
burning down a warehouse
and damaging surrounding homes.
The tears of this woman
falling on to a lost loved one.
Multiple dead
with hundreds of others wounded.
So as I'm about to come one kilometer,
we would only talk.
I knew
why the fire caught up with me
from almost one kilometer away
as I was escaping.
The flames from the explosion
knocked me down
burnt me on my neck and back,
as you can see.
Nairobi police are calling it
a crime scene
and opened an investigation on Friday.
Nearby, residents
watching in silent shock
as crime
investigators dig through the ash
at less than 24 hours ago
where their homes
business has hollowed out
this cause of the flames
abandoned these shop walls.
The extent of the damage
spreading for miles.
The gas explosion brings down everything
in its wake,
distracts
several structures, several hundred
yards in every direction.
One of the sixth floor rooftop,
almost one of the yards away,
broke down this wall
and most dramatic of all.
A car that was blasted all this way.
Parts of the car here, the rest of it
strewn all across this area.
And we're just a mile away
from Kenya's main airport
as we see a plane landing there.
Residents
of that building
telling me of their frantic escape
We don't and they fly on top of us.
So the gate was closed,
but we there was a stampede.
We hurriedly tried to get out.
I think
very many people were actually injured
at that moment.
Government officials
already dubbing the incident
as a consequence of corruption,
vowing to shut down
the unlicensed company
who was operating inside the cooking
gas filling plant.
It is totally immoral for one to risk
lives of fellow Kenyans
just for profit, mere profiteering.
It is not acceptable for such facilities.
To be resident
within residential areas
because these are innocent hustlers
who are going through their businesses
on a daily basis.
Rebuilding the damage could take months
or even years.
But in the hours
ahead, families
now having to face the reality of grief
right now.
So back on the street,
look at the damage in this car.
There's so many of them
across this neighborhood.
And this is just the impact of that
gas explosion that you see in this area.
The building
you saw in that piece,
by the way, that all the way back there,
you see the damage on the wall.
And the most extraordinary thing
having been in this scene,
because it's a densely populated area.
This explosion,
if it happened in the middle of the day,
there could have been hundreds
of casualties.
All the people you see here around.
These are people that live here.
If they were out on the streets
going about their business
and this happened.
The devastation would
have been unspeakable things.
Yeah, it's one blessing, isn't it?
Larry, thank you so much for
joining us from Nairobi.